what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness today we have a special
guest on the
show
Welcome hi introduce yourself to the
people hello hello I am Shahara also
known as the female skeptic I have a new
name online name and uh yeah I'm happy
to be back I came a few times
on the show and uh looking forward to
talking about what's what nonsense you
have for me today yes yes so um a little
background you know you're you're
actually studying to be a lawyer yes I
am I am a student of law I'm very
passionate about men's rights
particularly father's rights and I work
very closely with Charity which we're
hoping to take the child maintenance
service to court so really so what would
that look like it's like a mass lawsuit
yeah so it's uh it's called like a group
litigation so
uh basically like U various people come
together and we take one lawsuit against
the CMS okay um under an organization
called split the difference okay so and
how do people if they want to be a part
of it how do they contact it oh yeah um
absolutely they can visit split theed
difference.com okay and all the
information is there so you have been
coming on the show for over a year now
yes yes veteran yeah veteran and I was I
was just telling you before the show so
she has such a calming energy that
you've never been on a crazy show no no
I I I thank God yeah um okay so um guys
before we start make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams um so let's try to get this
video to 2,000 likes also guys make sure
you subscribe to the channel we're
trying to get to 2 million before the
end of the Year okay so um the first
story do you have any idea who Lana
rhods is no I don't okay so Lana rhs is
a porn star and when she was 18 she
started doing porn she did it for about
um she said she did like two stints of
four months so she only did really a
year okay but in that year she just
became like a very I guess well-known
porn star um and then after she quits
porn and she becomes a social media
influences and she is a girl that has
denounced porn like she said she was
manipulated which I don't
really I don't really B like sometimes I
just think chicks kind of say that to
dodge accountability right um I think it
was a poor choice I think she
acknowledges that yeah but I I don't
sometimes I'm like I I don't know how
like I've never seen her stuff but I
guess it was pretty graphic like like I
guess it was pretty good God yeah like I
I I can't remember the story they T I
don't even think I want to know but it
it was something like very like I think
it was extreme even for po oh my God
yeah like I know I know um okay so um
she actually ended up dating Logan
Paul's friend Mike so Logan Paul's a
best friend Mike they dated um I guess
he was a former drug addict she's a
former porn star they come together kind
of broken yeah you know whatever they it
ends up not working out
she ends up getting pregn oh no with
someone's kid not his not his no someone
else is they break up okay right okay
now we don't know who it is okay it's
speculated that it's an NBA star right
okay so now she is a single
mother
shocking it's interesting because I've
seen Clips too of her talking that about
that she used to be married before as
well wow you know to a prison I guess I
guess my God how old she um she I think
she's around my age so I think she's
around like 20s maybe like yeah so she's
lived a lot of life but I think she got
married at
18 ends up divorcing the husband he was
too controlling which is interesting so
I'm like well I I don't know you might
have been better off married to the
prisoner right I don't usually recommend
that life path but I'm like if we're if
these are the
options yeah do you know what I mean
like oh it sounds like cuz you're saying
that she made so many mistakes and she
doesn't you know she what was the option
being married or yeah being married to a
guy that went to prison I mean not a
great option no but or option
b do porn for a year become a social
media influencer and get pregnant with
an NBA player allegedly an NBA player
son right I guess on the bright side
she'll probably be paid out for 20 years
yeah
but I don't know I'm like in terms of
like respect life
satisfa you kind of respect El Chapo's
wife a little bit she's loyal you know
what I mean you know I mean God it's
kind of like you kind of have you seen
the CH you know what I'm talking about
she served like two years you're kind of
like
well right there's a
little so I want to get your take on
this video so she's talking actually now
about her how her view on men has
changed okay because her tune on men
before
was a bit they take advantage of me you
know they're so evil and bad and it's
not me making my own decisions but them
forcing me into those decisions okay
where I really think porn stars a lot of
them would work for free I think they're
bad business women right I think they
make like no money but but I genuinely
think they love the attention that it
brings them at the time but they don't
know the consequences that comes with it
that's my take okay so now she's talking
about how her view on men has changed
let's pull it up okay there's good guys
out there which by the way is another
thing that my pregnancy changed because
I had a boy I was very much a man hater
before I had my son and now I'm like I'm
still very much a girls girl but I'm
more of like an ally of all people
versus just women now because I look at
my son and how pure and innocent he is
and I'm like there's a little Milo and
all these men out there like they have a
mom that thinks about them the way that
I think about my son and that's really
helped me see that there are them a
little bit okay I mean she's being
honest good for her I
guess uh but yeah sorry I just can't
can't forget the way the the other one
was like yes same oh did you see who was
there I don't know who that is that's
Julia Fox oh my God is it s I couldn't
recognize her of course that's Julia Fox
I know I know that's what I
dominatrix we were just talking about
her before like she was like yeah same
that's my speciality actually but it's
interesting how you do see the mindset
shift a lot of times a bit when chicks
get older because they sort of realize
that maybe the man hatred wasn't all
that necessary yeah and and you know
like she said this is a pure innocent
Soul it's it's and and all men started
off like that believe it or not yeah and
guess what she's doing now also oh no
God what is it only F oh my God I swear
she has had a whole apology to her for
years what the hell years she has done a
whole apology to her saying I regret
this stuff that's a 18 180 I
and now she's but now she's only doing
the only fans that she doesn't feel
pressured into doing oh God so it's like
better right okay but it's sorry not a
180 that's a 360 isn't it she's just
going back to
school and and now with the child oh no
I know that's why when they give me
these ho apology tour I'm like I wanted
to believe it at first until I just see
so many of these chicks doing the same
thing they'll do the apology tour and
then start only fans yeah there is a
pattern definitely yeah and you know
this is what I say we really don't have
many gold standard women anymore so if
you are feeling unsure about your
finances these days you are not alone
that is why noble gold Investments is
here to help just hear it straight from
the folks that they have helped the
noble gold crew has walked me through
everything no stress and with their help
I can finally sleep easy at night and
now this month Noble gold Investments is
handing out a free 5 oz silver America
the Beautiful coin if you qualify for an
IRA investing gold and silver with Noble
gold Investments today go to noblegold
investments.com that's noblegold
investments.com they the only gold
company that I trust so you know there's
a lot of comments talking about what
this um chick was saying so she goes WTF
she went from a nine to a four yeah she
used to be a lot hotter like a lot but
it's interesting I feel like women that
make these choices hit the wall so much
quicker right like it's so interesting
they just age like I I like have you
seen like Pamela Anderson's another one
it just hits them hard because I don't
know if that's like cosmetic surgery or
well I don't know about that but yeah
definitely they look like they've been
through spends her life willingly being
an object for men and then complains at
how they treated her yeah no that's
that's how it is all the time you I'm
sorry but how old do you have to be to
start porn 18 yeah that that's it no
mistakes I'm sorry that's what I say
like because they always act like you're
18 you don't know what you're doing yeah
no no you you could say maybe you didn't
you know learn hard lessons but to act
like you didn't H like have any agency
in your decision yeah no because then
you're not being sincere you're not
being that crumbs the whole apology to
whatever I was a manher I think she
meant to say man
eater okay I don't know if that's an in
window or something I think it is
yeah damn she hit the wall she looks
like The Walking Dead good grief is that
she's got no makeup on but yeah I I
don't know I don't damn no makeup hit
yes oh my god oh no yeah but all of this
she she set she set herself up for all
of this yeah I don't know why where she
could have been married to a criminal
okay well even that could be debated we
don't even know the nature of well she
was could be innocent yeah yeah and she
was she was beautiful too so it wasn't
like that was her old choice no she was
cuz she was stunning back in the day she
was stunning what a shame but you know I
mean I even I was like even out of the
two options I was like I would still
pick if I had to pick married to a
criminal or ex porn star with a single
mother baby I I I would pick options and
only F Well yeah of course damn crazy
and and again what is
controlling what is controlling caring
about you trying to be
sensible yeah well because I think a lot
of times men have our best interests at
heart but because we're like because we
want to see them as the bad guy for
whatever reason it's like we take it as
controlling but really they're just
looking out for us yeah no exactly even
like I think of my dad every time my dad
has told me not to do something and I
have not listened he's always been right
yeah no same he's never he's never been
wrong say and maturity is when you
actually see that oh my dad cares about
me obviously yeah and my other half
cares about me yeah